Hey evolutionary cousins of bacteria, Trace
here for a DNews Short.
If you’ve ever been infected with Salmonella,
you’ll know how horrible the symptoms are,
including diarrhea, fever, and abdominal cramps.
But despite its debilitating and sometimes
deadly effects, researchers from Duke University
just developed a strain of the bacteria that
may be great at fighting cancer.
In particular, a brain cancer called glioblastoma,
which has been a thorn in the side of cancer
researchers for decades.
It is incredibly aggressive, and causes fast-growing
tumors in the brain.
The average survival time is just over a year,
and less than 10 percent of patients survive
for more than five years.
And what’s worse is that brain cancer isn’t
like other cancers, say lung or breast, because
those can be targeted more easily with conventional
chemotherapy.
But the brain doesn’t let those same methods
through due to something called the blood-brain
barrier.
This is a membrane surrounding the brain that
keeps out circulating blood and prevents the
brain from being exposed to harmful chemicals.
Unfortunately, this also means it blocks most
chemotherapy drugs that would be effective
against glioblastoma.
That’s where Salmonella comes in.
But not just any, run of the mill, uncooked
chicken-based Salmonella.
Researchers were able to genetically alter
the makeup of the bacteria so it was missing
a key amino acid called purine, which is commonly
found in tumors.
It was also programmed to produce harmful
compounds that cause cancer cells to self-destruct
in low-oxygen environments — inside a brain
tumor, for example.
When the bacteria is injected into the brain,
it bee-lines to get to the purine in the tumors
and then releases its compounds to kill the
cells.
Then, when the tumors are gone and there is
no purine left, the salmonella dies as well.
And just to make sure that the salmonella
itself doesn’t actually make you sick, the
team deactivated its toxicity.
Science is magic.
This method was tried out in rats, and resulted
in extending the life of 20% of those treated
by roughly 100 days, which equates about 10
human years.
Trials to genetically modify other kinds of
bacteria have been used for years.
Insulin can be produced for medicinal use
by a genetically modified type of E coli,
and another strain of E. coli can be altered
to act as an appetite suppressant, potentially
leading to an obesity cure.
There are some problems we humans can’t
solve on their own; sometimes, we need a little
genetically modified organism to do the job
for us.
Salmonella's normally associated with food
poisoning but do you even know what that is?
Find out in this video here.
Do you have any other crazy medical cures
you want us to look into?
Let us know down in the comments and make
sure you subscribe for more DNews.
Thanks for tuning in.